clearly it's a bonding moment for the  two of you did you have a moment with  the two of you up there  we did i mean we had a couple of those  moments especially we had about  i don't know 25 minutes on the ground  with the crew capsule sealed you know so  it's just the four of us  in there and my brother and i were we  picked seats so that we could see each  other from our seats  so we could look over and and and and we  had  we did we had some we had some really  good quality time there  and there was also a message that was  read from our  sister i know i have it oh god it was it  was good  i have it i have it it was beautiful she  says now hurry up and get your  back down here so i can give you a huge  hug we love you and godspeed new  shepherd yeah what did you when you  heard that from chris i  actually teared up right there in the  capsule yeah it was  um so heartfelt and you know she talked  about some of the things we did as kids  and  it was a very sweet message